Der Rasenfunk. Kurzpass. WM-Tag Nummer eins. Es geht endlich los mit unseren täglichen Kurzpässen und aus alter Gewohnheit. Fast schon sprechen wir mit der in Moskau lebenden Journalistin Katrin Scheib über diesen ersten Tag.
Los geht's.
Katrin, sei mir gegrüßt. Schön, dass wir wieder miteinander sprechen. Okay, das heißt wahrscheinlich irgendwie so was wie wurde auch Zeit oder endlich geht's los hier mit dem Rasenfunk. Guten Morgen. Ach ja, was für eine schöne, wohlklingende Sprache. Das habe ich mir so oft gedacht. Man hört jetzt ja viel mehr Russisch als sonst in seinem Leben. Zumindest in meinem bisherigen Leben war es so. Und es ist einfach eine schön klingende Sprache. Da kann man nichts gegen sagen. Wunderbar. Katrin, ich habe eine, ein Rätsel für dich. Was hat der Rasenfunk mit einem FIFA-Turnier gemeinsam? Hast du eine Idee?
Die massive Popularität natürlich. Eventuell hast du auch schöne Fähnchen.
Nein, nein, aber es geht schon in die richtige Richtung.
Du hast dir einen Wolf angeschafft, so als Maskottchen.
Oh, das wäre eine gute Idee gewesen. Aber es geht alles in die richtige Richtung. Nein, wir putzen uns heraus, wenn wir im Auge der Weltöffentlichkeit stehen. Der Rasenfunk erscheint jetzt mit dieser Folge hier, Katrin, in einem komplett neuen Outfit, mit einer neuen Webseite, mit neuen Logos, in einem neuen Design.
Ich habe schon die ganze Zeit gedacht, es klingt auch anders.
Ja, wir haben auch, also akustisch haben wir da, glaubst du gar nicht, was das für Filter drüberlaufen, dass ich mich anhöre wie ein Moderator. Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Nein, wir haben ein neues Design, das hat der liebe, liebe, liebe Manni Kostrinsky gemacht, at DiscoManni. Bei Twitter folgt ihm und huldigt ihm, denn wir haben im Grunde seit, naja, sagen wir, August letzten Jahres ging es los. Es startete ganz, ganz unschuldig mit einem neuen Logo, was wir haben wollten, und jetzt ist alles andere auch neu. Und der Frank hat die ganze Webseite programmiert, der Ed Helmi, ihr glaubt nicht, wie viele Nachtschichten wir die letzten Wochen hatten, vor allem die anderen beiden. Und jetzt ist es soweit mal online. Noch nicht alles fertig, aber so ist es ja immer beim, einem Re-Lounge schaut es euch an, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Das ist ja pädagogisch ein bisschen unklug, weil du mir das jetzt erzählst, jetzt will ich natürlich gucken und kann über wir reden müssen.
Ja, Dankeschön. Dankeschön. Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir es jetzt irgendwie letztendlich noch hingekriegt haben. So, aber wir wollen ja gar nicht so sehr über den Rasenfunk sprechen, sondern über die WM. Und ich gehe davon aus, wir haben dieses Thema Stimmung in Russland. Das durchzieht ja unsere gemeinsamen Kurzpässe. Das ist jetzt dann schon das vierte Mal oder fünfte Mal, dass wir miteinander sprechen. Siehst du, ich kann schon gar nicht mehr zählen, so viel. Wie ist es denn jetzt, wo es wirklich losgeht? Das letzte Mal hast du noch ein bisschen Witze drüber gemacht, wie wenig man im Stadtbild sieht. Jetzt ist aber volles WM-Feeling und nur noch Fußball, Fußball, Fußball, oder?
Was soll ich sagen, ehrlich gesagt, was einen totalen Unterschied gemacht hat, ist, dass seit ein paar Tagen halt die internationalen Fans in der Stadt sind. Und das hörst du und das siehst du und das macht richtig Vorfreude, wenn du in irgendeinem Café sitzt und da sitzen draußen drei Kolumbianer und dann kommen ein paar Leute aus Peru vorbei und dann gibt's Sprechgesänge hin und her, wer ist lauter, wer kann länger. Das ist total schön und gut gelaunt und entspannt. Aber es bleibt weiter so, im Stadtbild siehst du es halt da, wo irgendjemand offiziell ist oder manchmal vielleicht der Besitzer von einem Geschäft oder einem Supermarkt beschlossen hat, wir machen jetzt hier Deko. Also du siehst, wenn du was siehst, halt die offiziellen Fahnen mit den offiziellen Logos und eben Sabi Wacker, dem Wolf und dem Gagarin-Denkmal drauf und Kreml-Turm und sowas. Das sind ja diese bekannten, dieses sehr satte rot-blau, was sie da verwendet haben. Das siehst du viel. Fahnen ums Karl-Markts-Denkmal, Fahnen um die Lenin-Bibliothek, Fahnen um Pushkin. Aber ich habe immer noch keine einzige Fahne aus einem Fenster hängen sehen von einer Privatwohnung. Ich habe immer noch kein Fähnchen-Aufkleber oder diese albernen Rückspiegelteile an einem Auto gesehen.
Die Weitwinkelkondome nenne ich sie.
Sehr schön, sehr kreativ. Aha, ja, guck mal, die Teile. Nee, ehrlich gesagt, es ist so ein Droh zwischen dem, was offiziell hier in der Stadt so an Deko, mit WM-Bezug stattfindet und dem, was privat ist. Und privat ist da immer noch nicht viel. Klar, um die Stadien herum siehst du es, aber das ist ja dann auch wieder. Das sind offizielle Spielorte, da wird offiziell dekoriert.
Und hat das mit der Erwartungshaltung zu tun, an die eigene Mannschaft? Denn die erste Fahne, die man ja aus dem Fenster hängen würde, ist vielleicht auch das Ratsamste. Wäre ja die eigene und vielleicht sind da die Erwartungen nicht so groß. Jetzt geht es ja heute Abend los gegen Saudi-Arabien.
Also es stimmt sicher, dass die meisten Russen das entweder realistisch oder sogar mit so einem gewissen schwarzen Humor sehen. Aber ich glaube, da spielt noch was anderes rein. Ich habe mich letzte Woche, vorletzte Woche, mit einer Expertin getroffen für Urbanismus und eine Stadtplanerin quasi und die hat ganz viel darüber erzählt, wie wenig, gerade noch mehr in Moskau, in der Hauptstadt, es die Leute gewohnt sind, dass sie sowas überhaupt dürfen und dass das erwünscht ist, dass sie sich irgendwie einbringen und auf der Straße, weißt du, dass sie ihren Fernseher ins Fenster drehen oder dass sie ein Bierfestchen vor die Haustür stellen, wenn einer vorbeikommt, ein anderer Fan oder auch nur eben was aus dem Fenster hängen lassen, weil ja, also von der Gesprächspartnerin, der Schwerpunkt ist halt Stadtplan und die hat gesagt, natürlich in der Sowjetunion wurde alles immer von oben weg entschieden, was jetzt gebaut wird und was nicht, dann ist Moskau ja in den letzten paar Jahren unfassbar umgebaut worden. Die Parks wurden einmal so durchgeglättet und aufgehipstert und haben jetzt alle freies W-Laden, die Straßen haben Spuren verloren zugunsten von breiteren Bürgersteigen und Radwegen und Grünungen und Bänken und das sind alles gute Sachen, hat aber halt niemand mitreden dürfen, wurde auch wieder komplett mal von oben entschieden und dadurch gibt es halt so überhaupt nicht das Gefühl, das ist meins, das gehört mir und das ist ein Freiraum, der ist entstanden, damit ich da auch was machen kann und was tun wir denn jetzt damit?
Also macht man das dann vielleicht eher in seinem Wohnzimmer?
Das kann gut sein. Also die Freunde, bei denen ich jetzt zuletzt war, nicht, aber es ist ja nun auch nicht jeder Fußballfan und muss ja auch nicht in jedem Land das so bekloppt sein wie in Deutschland, oder so weit verbreitet, aber ja, also sie sagte halt ganz klug, was soll ich eine Fahne ins Fenster hängen, wenn ich mir erstens nicht hundertprozentig sicher bin, ob das im Moment dann doch vielleicht mal, also ob das erlaubt und gut geheißen ist oder ob es mir Ärger macht, Probleme, Tamtam, weil eben so vieles einem Ärger macht oder Probleme, wenn man es tut.
Ja, ganz interessanter Punkt. Das streift ja dann auch so ein bisschen den Themenkomplex, dass zum Beispiel das Demonstrationsverbot noch mal verschärft wurde vor der WM und jetzt haben wir so einen komischen Clash of Cultures, der irgendwie vielleicht auch ganz nett ist, weil er den Finger so ein bisschen drauf zeigt, dass sich Fußballfans, die aktuell aus anderen Ländern anreisen nach Russland, sehr wahrscheinlich viel, viel mehr erlauben können, als die Bürger des Landes, das sie besuchen.
Ja, das ist definitiv so, also wie du sagst, Versammlungsfreiheit noch strenger eingeschränkt in den WM-Auftragungsorten und gleichzeitig halt Fans, die aus aller Welt kommen und die das zum Teil gar nicht wissen und die einfach halt tun, was man als Fan so tut. Also es gab da gestern der Mark Bennis, das ist hier ein Journalist in Moskau, der war in der Stadt unterwegs und war an der Stelle und hat ein Foto gemacht, wo irgendwie so ein paar Uruguay-Fans ein Uruguay-Banner ausrollen. Und das ist ja komplett Standard-Verhalten, du stellst dich dahin, transparent, unterstützt deine Mannschaft. In genau derselben Situation sind in Moskau schon Leute verhaftet worden, die dort leere Zettel, weißes Papier, hochgehalten haben, um zu protestieren gegen die Einschränkung des Versammlungsrechts. Es gibt Leute, die sind verhaftet worden, weil sie die russische Verfassung hochgehalten haben als gebundenes Buch. Oder zum Beispiel kleinere Sachen, ich habe heute früh noch mal eine Runde gedreht, bin mit dem Bus in die Stadt gefahren, habe geguckt, was man so sieht oder auch nicht sieht von der WM. Und es gibt vor der Manege, also das ist so in Sichtweite vom Roten Platz, gibt es den sogenannten Manegenplatz, da sind aufgestellt jeweils diese Umrisse von einer Sehenswürdigkeit aus einem Austragungsort. Und am Rand steht so eine Sabiwaka-Statue. Und auf die war gerade so ein Fan aus Peru hochgeklettert, hatte dem einen Peru-Schal umgehängt und posierte nun also. Und dann kommt ein Polizist vorbei und lässt das geschehen. Und das ist in diesen Tagen echt besonders, dass das in Ordnung ist und dass das nicht heißt, na jetzt kommt er aber zack hier runter hier. Das ist hier alles, muss hier seine Ordnung haben, das wird hier nicht auf Statuen geklettert. Also da müssen viele Leute, Sicherheitskräfte gerade lernen, Sachen anders zu bewerten, als sie das sonst täten. Wo sonst halt die klare Ansage sein wird, durchgreifen, abbrechen, verhaften und plötzlich passieren so Sachen hier.
Ja, das ist schon Wahnsinn. Wir haben uns ja auch in der letzten Kurzpass noch darüber unterhalten, dass bei einer Demonstration 2000 Demonstranten festgenommen wurden. Also 2000. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist das Demonstrationsverbot inzwischen soweit ausgeweitet, dass eben auch, wenn ich mich jetzt alleine irgendwo hinstellen würde und gegen etwas demonstrieren wollen würde, wo, glaube ich, ganz viele Menschen sagen würden, Moment, das ist ja noch keine Demo, dass das schon verboten ist.
Das stimmt. Das ist quasi eine Einpersonendemo. Und da ist gerade wieder jemand festgenommen worden, der –also muss man eins vorher ausholen –es gibt ja hier diese Studentenproteste gegen die Fanzone oben an der Uni aus Angst vor Lärm in der Prüfungsphase und so weiter. Dann ist ein Student festgenommen worden, weil er auf so einen WM-Aufsteller, so ein Wegweiserteil, den Slogan keine Fanzone gesprüht hatte. Dass das in Deutschland auch als Vandalismus gesehen wird und wahrscheinlich ein Bußgeld gibt oder so was. Der Typ ist festgesetzt worden, dem drohten eine hohe Geldstrafe. Ich meine es sind 65.000 Rupe. 1.000 Rupe sind 14 Euro, 10.000 sind also 140. Das heißt du warst so 800 Euro für einen Studenten und nicht nach deutschen Dimensionen, sondern mit russischem Einkommen, was natürlich nochmal eine ganz andere Klasse ist. Dem bist du Gefängnis gedroht und dann hat eben jemand anders als ein Mantrotest sich auf die Straße gestellt mit einem Schild, um den zu unterstützen und den haben sie sich auch direkt gegriffen. Der musste dann auch eine Strafe bezahlen dafür. Den Sprayer haben sie freigelassen, da haben sie entschieden, das ist kein Vandalismus. Wahrscheinlich auch, weil dieser Fall viel Öffentlichkeit gekriegt hat. Aber weißt du, wenn du eine Stufe kleiner bist, dann ist es nur noch der, der andere Protestierenden unterstützt und es guckt nicht mehr die ganze Welt Öffentlichkeit kurz vor der WM. Wie verhalten die sich denn da? Ja, und dann passiert dann doch wieder sowas.
Wie stehst du dem gegenüber, du bist ja auch in einer besonderen Rolle, dass du in Moskau lebst, aber quasi die Wertevorstellungen und auch eine andere persönliche Lebenswelt aus Deutschland ja noch mitbringst. Findest du es wichtig, dass man auch solche Themen jetzt immer wieder aufs Neue nennt, auch wenn wir alle im totalen Fußballfieber sind, weil Russland gegen Saudi-Arabien das krasseste Eröffnungsspiel aller Zeiten war, mit diesem 8 zu 7 nach der ersten Hauptzeit?
Ja, natürlich finde ich das wichtig. Und ich glaube auch, dass man beides kann, so wie wir in unserem Alltag auch, wenn man auch nur halbwegs politisch interessierter Mensch ist, heißt das ja auch nicht, dass man nicht Lebensfreude hat und gerne was mit Freunden unternimmt und abends zusammen sitzt und diskutiert. Aber dass du eben nicht immer nur, also dass du auch über politische Themen diskutierst, das heißt ja nicht, dass das dein Leben jede Sekunde bestimmt, das ist eine Frage von Bewusstsein. Und natürlich ist das wichtig hier. Natürlich sollte man sich vergegenwärtigen, dass man, wenn man hier hinkommt als ausländischer Fan, eine große Ladung Privileg mit sich mitbringt. Das, was ich eben schon erklärt habe natürlich, dass einem Sachen durchgegangen gelassen werden, die bei Russen so nicht durchgingen, aber auch finanzielles Privileg natürlich. Also du kommst hier in ein Land, gerade wenn du jetzt aus einem EU-Land kommst, dann hast du wahrscheinlich ein anderes Einkommensniveau und findest, selbst wenn Moskau als Stadt teuer ist, im Vergleich dazu, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel, weiß ich nicht, in Yekaterinburg oder so bist, wirst du viele sicherlich, oder Wolkegrad, als günstig empfinden. Du hast das Privileg, in vielen Fällen, wenn du aus dem Westen anreist, weiß zu sein. Du wirst also nicht, hab ich ja oft gesagt, du wirst nicht einfach in der Metro rausgewunken, schikaniert, kontrolliert, unwirsch angepfläumt und so weiter. Also check your privilege, jedes Mal wieder.
Genau, und trotzdem geht es jetzt dann auch mit dem Sportlichen los. Wir haben die Erwartungshaltung gerade schon so ein bisschen gestreift und ich habe eine Frage, die so in der Mitte liegt zwischen Politik und Sport. Deswegen möchte ich sie jetzt an dieser Stelle hier stellen. Im WM-Podcast der Süddeutschen Zeitung gab es die Auftaktfolge mit Thomas Kistner und Johannes Aumüller und die haben eben sehr auch diesen politischen Hintergrund der WM beleuchtet und ich glaube, es war Thomas Kistner, der sehr fest davon überzeugt war, dass man alles dafür tun würde, von Seiten der FIFA Russland möglichst weit durch dieses Turnier zu schieben. Er hat da als Beispiel die Gruppe genannt, da haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, es war sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass es diese besonders leichte Gruppe gibt und durch die Aussagen von Michel Platini, der jetzt zugegeben hat zur WM98, haben wir schon geguckt, dass der Gastgeber Frankreich, Brasilien möglichst bis zum Finale aus dem Weg geht. Fand ich interessant, wie wenig Widerhörer es eigentlich gefunden hatte, diese Aussage. Ja, das hatte ich auch noch nicht gehört. Und auch der Spielplan passt ganz gut, also jetzt den vermeintlich leichtesten Gegner zu Beginn, dann könnte man sich einen Dreier holen und dann könnte man durchrutschen und er hat das so weit getrieben, dass er dann sogar gemeint hat, er glaubt, man versucht, die durchzuziehen bis zum Viertelfinale, Halbfinale. Geht so ein bisschen in eine Verschwörungstheoretische Richtung, hältst du das denn überhaupt für möglich?
Nee, du hörst mich hier gerade tief ausatmen und ich musste gerade als du es sagtest schon einmal machen. Also jedem seine Meinung und den Ehren und natürlich, es ist jetzt nicht, dass man von der FIFA nicht immer mal wieder negativ überrascht werden könnte, aber das halte ich, das halte ich deshalb auch für unwahrscheinlich, weil du da einfach viel mehr beeinflussen musst. Du musst ja dann wirklich auch den Gegner beeinflussen, klar. Selbst wenn du unterstellst, was ich nicht tun würde, dass da irgendwie gedreht wurde am Spielplan. Was willst du denn als nächstes machen, dafür sorgen, also du kannst ja maximal dann halt eine der leichteren Mannschaften zulosen oder, ne, aber dann musst du ja die in der nächsten Gruppe beeinflussen, wer wird dann der Gruppe in erster, zweiter, gegen wen der spielt. Also, nee, überzeugt mich nicht.
Es ist ein bisschen weit weg vielleicht wegen der sportlichen Leistungsfähigkeit der russischen Mannschaft. Also, in Frankreich 1998 irgendwie einen solchen Turnierbaum zu geben, dass ein Finale möglich ist im eigenen Land, war halt auch deshalb möglich, weil da eine Generation von Fußballern gespielt hat, die es so halt vorher in Frankreich nicht gab in der Nationalmannschaft. Das ist jetzt in Russland nicht ganz so oder werden wir Statuen erleben? Ja, ich bin auch sehr gespannt. Spielt denn das Sportliche jetzt eine große Rolle jetzt am heutigen Tage? Also wenn wir uns zurück erinnern, wie zum Beispiel die WM-Eröffnung 2006 in Deutschland war, da konnte man nichts anderes lesen, schon Tage vorher als Portraits von Costa Rica. Es wurde einem um die Ohren gehauen, dass Urs Siegenthaler bei seiner Spielanalyse auch die Landesmentalität mit einplant. Also man konnte sich auch vor sportlicher Vorberichterstattung nicht retten. Ist es in Russland ähnlich gerade?
Ja, also jetzt natürlich. In dieser Woche gibt es richtig, richtig viel Vorberichterstattung und auch drumherum Berichterstattung. Also jetzt gerade gab es zum Beispiel Porträts, ich glaube in Vedomosti, von jedem einzelnen Trainer. Also auch ein großes Stück über Löw.
Klar, da findet total viel statt jetzt, aber …War das das Stück, in dem du erfahren hast, dass er nebenberuflich mal Krawatten verkauft hat?
Ja, wusstest du das?
Nein, das wusste ich auch nicht.
Guck mal.
Ich war sehr dankbar, dass ich das bei dir im Russball gelesen habe.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, da hast du wahrscheinlich wieder mal eine russische Vokabel, die du nicht beherrschst, oder es ist eine Redensart. Was heißt das denn da mit der Krawatte? Du googlst das mal und dann habe ich auch gefunden, dass er wirklich Krawatten verkauft hat und dass es keine Redensart ist für irgendwas anderes. Also es gibt irgendwo aus der Schweiz auch ein Stück, wo das drin vorkommt, wo ich es dann deutschsprachig nachlesen konnte. Na gut, interessant an Löw ist natürlich, wenn du jetzt als russische Zeitung drüber schreibst, diese Perspektive, sein Vater in sowjetischer Kriegsgefangenschaft. Diese Anekdote liest man dann halt öfter. Und dass er als Trainer ja quasi mal der Chef von Chechev, dem russischen Nationaltrainer, war in Innsbruck.
Beim FC Tirol, Innsbruck war das so. Deswegen haben die jetzt auch noch so ein gutes Verhältnis miteinander und Chechev hatte die Ehre, würde ich sagen, bei der deutschen WM-Kaderbekanntgabe als Hologramm bei der Pressekonferenz zu sein. Ich finde es schön, dass der Fußball nicht überdreht.
Nee, und auch gerade, dass sie alles immer gut auf Star-Trek-Niveau halten.
Ja, wenn es wenigstens Star-Trek-Niveau gehabt hätte. Aber es hatte immerhin eine gewisse Komik, man soll ja nicht undankbar sein. Wenn wir übrigens bei so sportpolitischen Themen sind, dann kann man ja auch noch über den FIFA-Kongress von gestern sprechen. Da fand ich sehr beeindruckend im negativen Sinne. Es war nicht überraschend, aber die Art und Weise, wie Vladimir Putin da gefeiert wurde mit Standing Ovations, der kompletten Delegation und auch, wie er dann jetzt schon Wahlkampf für Gianni Infantino gemacht hat, in dem er Dinge gesagt hat, wie er habe die FIFA in schweren Zeiten stark geleitet, er blieb ruhig, er ist ein echter Kämpfer. Also, gerade, dass sie sich nicht noch ein Zimmer genommen haben auf der Bühne. Nicht ganz überraschend, ich vermute, das wird uns aber jetzt dann auch über die Offenungsfeier noch mit begleiten, dieses sich gegenseitige Anhimmeln und Verliebtsein.
Na ja, gleich und gleich, oder? Autoritär strukturierte korrupte Männersysteme. Erkennen sich dann vielleicht auch und haben sich gern und verstärken sich, stärken sich aneinander den Rücken.
Es ist wirklich interessant. Und an der Stelle auch noch ein anderer Hinweis, das habe ich jetzt gerade ganz, ganz kurz vor unserer Aufzeichnung erst noch gelesen. Die WM ist ja immer ein Zeitpunkt, in dem man sehr genau gucken muss, was gibt es eigentlich so in anderen Lebensbereichen für Meldungen. Ganz, ganz berühmt sind so manche Bundestagsabstimmungen, bei denen nur zwei Leute teilgenommen haben, überspitzt formuliert. Und jetzt habe ich gelesen und das Datum auf kicker.de, wo ich die Märchen jetzt zuerst gesehen habe, ist von gestern Abend. Ich vermute, dass da auch die Pressemitteilung rausgeht. Die UEFA hat gestern Abend ganz, ganz zufällig kurz vor dem WM-Hype verkündet, dass man die Ermittlungen wegen Verstoßes gegen das Financial Fair Play gegen Paris, sage ich mal, wir erinnern uns, Mbappé und Neymar, erstmal eingestellt hat, weil man nichts gefunden hat.
Ja super, also das ist ja das klassische Meldung vergraben.
Total. Und ich vermute auch, es wird sehr gut funktionieren. Deswegen wollte ich es hier nennen, obwohl es eigentlich mit dieser Folge nicht so direkt was zu tun hat. Aber einfach, einfach Wahnsinn, diese großen Organisationen. Und man muss auch selbst als Journalist, finde ich, ein so offenes Auge haben, dass einem selber nicht auch Dinge durchrutschen und wahrscheinlich rutschen einem auch tausend Dinge durch.
Ja, mehr Power für die Kollegen vom Kicker, dass sie es gemeldet haben.
Sehr gut, absolut.
Okay, kommen wir zurück zur WM. Ich habe, ach ich habe, ich erfahre ja in deine NTV-Kolumne, es ist ein Jammer, dass die vorbei ist und im Russball habe ich so viele nette Geschichten erfahren. Und einen Aspekt, da habe ich mich dann darüber gewundert, warum wir da noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen haben, denn eigentlich liegt es nahe, du hast geschrieben, manche Mannschaften, nämlich die, die in Sankt Petersburg beheimatet sind, sind ja von den berühmten weißen Nächten betroffen. Das heißt, in Sankt Petersburg wird es nicht richtig dunkel. Liegt total nahe. Hast du gerade auf dem Schirm, welche Mannschaften das sind?
Also ich weiß, dass England da in der Nähe untergebracht ist. Wir haben gute Vorhänge. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob da noch mehr sind. Ich habe jetzt leider gerade die Karte mit den Quartieren nicht vor Augen. Aber Petersburg natürlich ist eine der großen Austragsorte bis hin zu, ich glaube, ein Halbfinale. Es ist also logistisch nicht ganz unglücklich, da in der Nähe zu sein. Kann sein, dass da noch ein, zwei mehr sind. Und ich meine, es muss ja dann auch gar nicht zwingend Petersburg sein. Also du kriegst das auch hier in Moskau schon ganz gut mit. Wir haben eigentlich nur so ein paar Stunden Nacht im Moment. Das ist immer das Klassische. So, verschlafen, ab ins Bad, Zähne putzen und dann feststellen, es ist drei Uhr morgens.
Wie ist es dann in St. Petersburg, wenn du es in Moskau schon merkst, wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Einfach richtig hell.
Die ganze Nacht über.
Genau, es ist halt vielleicht ein bisschen dämmeriger, aber so, dass du immer noch gut eine Zeitung oder ein Buch auf der Straße lesen könntest, ohne dass du dir leuchten musst. Ich war tatsächlich 1997 oder 1998 das erste Mal in Russland, in Petersburg, auf einer Chorfahrt damals. Und da waren auch genau weiße Nächte. Du guckst aus dem Fenster und es fühlt sich auch an wie Tag. Das habe ich sonst nur erlebt, als ich mal im Sommer in Finnland war.
Das schmeißt einen schon ganz schön aus dem Biorhythmus. Jetzt könnte man doch die Verschwörungstheorie weiter drängen. Bestimmt wurde auch beschlossen, dass Saudi-Arabien nach St. Petersburg muss, denn die sind dann nämlich auch zusammen noch mit Südkorea, Costa Rica ist auch noch in St. Petersburg, Kroatien, England haben wir schon genannt.
Ja oder England hat eine super, super, super Entschuldigung für alles, was man demnächst vielleicht wieder in die Hose geht.
Wir konnten den Elfmeter nicht halten, wir waren so müde.
Genau, ach so schlecht geschlafen letzte Nacht. Es gibt hier in Moskau übrigens eine Kneipe, die hat ausgerufen, bei allen England-Spielen gibt es für jedes England-Tor einen gratis Wodka für alle Anwesenden. Ich glaube, die haben dann so eine Flasche Wodka nochmal auf halbe gestellt.
Ich glaube, die werden sich sehr genau angeguckt haben, in welcher Gruppe England nur 18 Tore gemacht hat in der WM-Qualifikation. Aber gut, wer weiß, wir wollen das auch nicht. Es tut mir auch fast schon leid, dass ich dieses Elfmeter-Klischee da bedient habe. Eigentlich soll es ja so platt hier nicht sein. Lassen wir sie erst mal spielen und dann lassen wir uns auch sehr gerne positiv überraschen. Wird aber noch eine Weile dauern, bis England gegen Tunesien am nächsten Montag ins Turnier eingreift.
Ist das dann in Kaliningrad? Das ist in Wolgokrad. Ach so, aber ich weiß, wir haben auch eins in Kaliningrad. Weil, glaube ich, da mehr englische Fans hinreisen, weil es halt näher ist, den ganzen Tag.
Ach ja, das ist ja schon das Schöne. Man lernt jetzt auch Russland noch mal näher kennen. Ich meine, wir zwei sprechen jetzt schon seit Dezember über die WM-Russland. Und jedes Mal, also ich lese ja sowieso den Russball und deine Kolumnen habe ich immer gelesen. Und jedes Mal habe ich aber noch mal ein bisschen vorrecherchiert und mir Dinge angeguckt. Und trotzdem erfahre ich so viele neue Dinge allein über dieses Land. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie schlecht man sich in Landeskunde auskennt im Grunde.
Total, weil es halt auch, ich glaube, es hat verschiedene Läden. Das eine ist halt eine ganz praktische, bürokratische Hemmschwelle durch das ganze Tamtam mit dem Visum. Was ehrlich gesagt, wenn du ein gutes Reisebüro hast, gar nicht so viel Tamtam ist, weil ich kann nur jedem Befehl nicht selber aufs Konsulat zu fahren und da rumzusitzen, sondern sich ein gutes Reisebüro zu suchen, was auf sowas spezialisiert ist und einem das für gar nicht so viel Geld macht. Also ich glaube, das ist halt eine praktische Sache. Du wirst halt nicht sagen, ach komm, Städtereise am Wochenende, jetzt machen wir mal Moskau statt Barcelona oder so. Und das andere ist natürlich, dass so vieles immer noch natürlich historisch besetzt ist, dass halt die Großvätergeneration nach Hause gekommen ist, schwer traumatisiert mit Geschichten aus einem Land, wo es immer eisig kalt ist und wo Menschen erfroren sind. Und wie immer muss man natürlich sagen, auf beiden Seiten schwer traumatisierte Menschen, das soll jetzt nicht irgendwie kleinreden, dass es natürlich, dass Deutschland diesen Krieg vom Zaun gebrochen hat. Ich meine nur, also das ist natürlich im deutschen Bewusstsein, sind diese Geschichten immer noch so tief drin. Als wir hier frisch hingegangen sind, eine bekannt aus dem erweiterten Familienkreis, schon deutlich ältere Dame, hat lange gefragt, nicht wann kommt ihr denn zurück, sondern wann dürft ihr denn zurück? Dann musst du mir immer sagen, wir gehen da ja freiwillig hin, und wir finden das interessant, und das ist bestimmt nicht alles einfach, aber wir wollen da ja hin und wir wollen uns das anschauen und gucken, wie es dann ist und wie du sagst, auch immer wieder neue Sachen rausfinden.
Es gibt ein tiefes Unbehagen gegenüber dem Osten. Jetzt als jemand, der in Westeuropa und im globalen Westen vielleicht betrachtet, das merkst du auch in komplett jeder Berichterstattung, egal ob wir uns dann angucken, wir haben deutsche Medien über diesen Skripal-Vorfall berichtet, noch über andere Dinge, auch wie wird jetzt über die WM wahrscheinlich berichtet werden. Und nie vergessen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir haben uns ja gerade auch um eine Europameisterschaft beworben. Also ob dann Deutschland so viel besser ist bei vielen Dingen als das, wo man jetzt mit dem Finger drauf zeigt, das wird sich erst noch erweisen müssen. Und mit Blick auf die WM 2006 würde ich sagen, von weißen Westen kann man da, glaube ich, nicht ausgehen.
Aber ich weiß, du hast es nicht so gemeint, aber ich glaube, in Sachen Rechtsstaatlichkeit, demokratische Grundprinzipien, muss man schon immer noch mal kurz sagen, das ist alles. Du meinst jetzt bzgl. die Baustelle Korruption.
Nee, und ich meinte so was wie Kommerzialisierung und sich komplett den Kommerzinteressen eines Verbandes ausliefern. Sowas meinte ich jetzt. Nee, nee, also ich möchte jetzt nicht die... Das haben wir ja, glaube ich, schon ganz gut umrissen, das Einmangel. Ich glaube auch. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr, ein sehr plakatives Beispiel. Und auch alles, was man rund um die Nationen lesen kann, die in Grosny oder in der Nähe stationiert sind, also stationiert, wollten wir nicht diesen Militär...
Untergebracht.
Untergebracht sind. Das ist ja auch ein so großes Thema. Allein darüber könnte man ja Stunden reden. Was mit dieser Region, mit dieser Stadt passiert ist. Ich habe einen Artikel gelesen, da hieß es, vor 20 Jahren hätte Grosny noch ausgesehen wie Dresden 45. Ich weiß es nicht, aber allein, dass ein Journalist, eine Journalistin, was, glaube ich, in dem Fall sich zu so einem drastischen Vergleich begibt, wird es auf jeden Fall zeigen, okay, da sah es sehr schlimm aus. Jetzt sieht es ein bisschen aus wie Dubai ist eben dann der nächste Satz gewesen. Dann haben wir Mosalla, der sich mit Ramzan Kadyrov, dem tschetschinischen Machthaber, fotografieren lässt, der in Tschetschinen eben Schwule verfolgt. Menschenrechte werden auch da ignoriert. Eigentlich könnte man bei dieser WM tatsächlich fast nur über politisches reden. Das ist Wahnsinn.
Ja, also gerade dieses, also dieses, es ist natürlich, wenn du siehst dieses Mosalla-Foto und bist natürlich sofort, erinnert an das Erdogan-Foto, aber das hier ist natürlich nochmal ein ganz anderes Kaliber. Und das ist, das hilft Kadyrov so sehr, dieses Foto, weil der ist, der ist schon jetzt in Russland, der ist mächtig, Putin braucht den, weil das so, das ist der eine starke Mann und eben auch Moslem, der sagt trotzdem hier in dieser Region, wir stehen zu Putin, der ist extrem loyal, aber dafür kriegt er natürlich, ich meine, es ist kein Wunder, dass Grosny heute so aussieht, wie es aussieht. Und im Gegenzug gibt es dann eben alle paar Monate wieder diese öffentlichen, wie sagt man, wie hieß das früher, diese Vasallen-Bezeugungen, das ist weiter hier, Putin ist weiter unserer und ich bin zu ihm loyal.
Ja, es ist wirklich ein spannendes Turnier. Ich bin auch gespannt, wie es sich hier im Rasenfunk die Waage halten wird. Natürlich geht es hier immer erst mal um Sportliche und sobald dann die Spiele gespielt sind, werden die besprochen. Aber ich werde schon versuchen, auch immer diese Nebenthemen hier nochmal anzusprechen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ansonsten gibt es auch noch einen weiteren WM-Podcast von der Taz, Russisch Brot heißt der, und die haben sich vorgenommen, noch mehr auf die politischen Hintergründe einzugehen. Ich denke, da habe ich jetzt bisher, glaube ich, erst eine Folge, die zweite konnte ich noch nicht hören. Ich empfehle den jetzt einfach mal an der Stelle. Aber natürlich immer erst nachdem ihr den Rasenfunk gehört habt. Das ist ja sowieso klar, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Jetzt haben wir ja auch noch den Themenkomplex HAYO SEPPELD. Haben wir letztes Mal schon drüber gesprochen. Die neueste Entwicklung dazu ist, er wird nicht nach Russland reisen, nachdem er sich auseinandergesetzt hat, mit Einschätzungen des BKA und des BNDs, die ihm gesagt haben, also du würdest da eine Gefahr für Leib und Leben eingehen und dieses Risikus ihm zu hoch eventuell auch damit zusammenhängt, dass er jetzt angekündigt hat, es kommen noch neue Enthüllungen rund um das Doping-System in Russland. Wir haben ja schon das letzte Mal drüber gesprochen, dass das logischerweise von russischer Seite aus ganz, ganz anders thematisiert wird als von deutscher Seite aus und dass es eher so genutzt wurde, um zu sagen, ja guckt mal, sogar den lassen wir rein, sogar unserem größten Kritiker stellen wir uns.
Im zweiten Anlauf, muss man sagen.
Im zweiten Anlauf, genau. Aber über den hat man ja nicht so groß berichtet dann, dass es... Findet diese Personalie jetzt immer noch statt? Wird das so ein Dauerthema sein? Also gerade als deutsche Journalistin wirst du ja wahrscheinlich dann einmal häufiger mit dem Thema konfrontiert als vielleicht andere.
Also ehrlich gesagt habe ich zu der neuen Entwicklung, dass er jetzt entschieden hat, nicht zu kommen, noch nichts gesehen. Das ist ja von was? Gestern Abend, glaube ich.
Gestern Abend, genau.
Also sehr gut. Ich habe heute früh ehrlich gesagt noch nicht quergucken können, weil ich gerade noch mal kurz in der Stadt unterwegs war heute Morgen. Und jetzt reden wir ja schon. Ich gehe davon aus, dass das noch mal gemeldet wird. Ich gehe davon aus, dass das auch noch mal einiges an Kommentaren hervorruft. Aber ich kann dir da leider jetzt noch nichts erzählen, was ich wirklich gesehen hätte.
Aber wir wollen, ich habe mir das auch fest vorgenommen, ich will auch nicht immer hier dämonisch mit dem Finger auf das Land Russland zeigen. Es gibt auch, auch wenn man mit bedenken muss, Menschenrechtslage, alles überhaupt nicht gut und das soll thematisiert werden, aber es gibt auch die positiven Geschichten und die sollen auch ihren Platz finden. Und eine davon hast du erlebt, Katrin. Und wenn ich jetzt sage, dass es damit zusammenhängt, dass du mit elf Polizisten zu tun hattest innerhalb einer Nacht eigentlich.
Und es war keine Fußballmannschaft, es war nicht der Betriebssport.
Ach ja, stimmt, genau, das wäre eigentlich nett gewesen. Dann muss ich sagen, hol uns da nochmal kurz rein, du hast da einen so schönen Text geschrieben, den werde ich auch in den Show notes verlinken. Aber gib mal einen kleinen Teaser für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, um was ging es denn?
Ja, also das Schöne an WM ist halt, gerade wenn du Journalistin bist, dass Freunde aus Deutschland, die auch Journalisten sind, dann plötzlich in der Stadt sind. Und man kann sich auf ein Bier treffen und zwischendurch mal quatschen und so. Und so kam eben ein Freund aus Berlin, der für eine große Nachrichtenagentur arbeitet und den ich jetzt hier natürlich nicht identifizieren werde, weil er mir diesen Abend eingebrockt hat. Aber sagen wir mal, er heißt R, R-Punkt. Und kam an und am ersten Tag alles geklärt, Akkreditierung. Und am zweiten Tag wollten wir Abendessen gehen. Und er kommt rüber und bei uns, ich wohne in so einem Wohngelände, so eine kleine Anlage, am Eingang ist eine Schranke mit so einem Wertehäuschen. Und wenn da jemand kommt, wollen die immer einmal den Pass sehen. Und da fiel auch, dass er seinen Pass nicht mehr hatte. Und dann haben wir, naja, Metro hat Lain angerufen, ein paar Sachen. Er ist den Weg abgelaufen. Und dann hat er sich an der Metrostation an die Polizei gewandt. Und dann hat die Moskauer Polizei versucht, zu zeigen, was sie kann. Und hat mit einem hohen Aufwand an Personal, mit einem hohen Aufwand an Bürokratie, an rumgegondelt durch die Stadt, weil verschiedene, weil der Ort, wo er gemerkt hat, dass er den Pass nicht mehr hat. Und den Ort, wo er sich an die Polizei gewandt hat. Und der Ort, wo er in die Metro, das sind alles verschiedene Polizei-Reviere. Die müssen dann alle eingebunden werden. Und dann fahren wir alle noch mal zu diesen Wärterhäuschen, wo er nun diese Erkenntnis hatte. Und plötzlich stehst du da und um dich rumstehen. Da sind halt fast ein Dutzend Polizisten.
Wegen eines verlorenen Passes.
Wegen eines verlorenen Passes. Einer in blauem Tarnfleck mit Schutzweste und Schäferhund. Einer mit dem Fotoapparat, der macht da ein Foto, wie er hier am Wärterhäuschen steht. In dem Moment, wo er stand, wo er begriffen hat, dass er seinen Pass nicht mehr hat. Einer in zivil, der eine nach der anderen raucht. Was ist so? Und es ist wie ein Kammerspiel. Und nicht nur bin ich zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben in einem russischen Polizeiauto gefahren. Und auch noch in einer sehr netten Atmosphäre, wo zwischendurch immer so Fußballsmalltalk, ach, deshalb sind sie hier, ja, ich hab ja mal im Wembley-Stadion die und die spielen sehen. Und was sagen sie denn eigentlich zu Lester, wie die da Meister geworden sind. Und es zog sich aber einfach. Wir haben um sieben angefangen. Und hier knackend ist halt, dass hier mein Besuch, der spricht kein Russisch. Und ich spreche okay Russisch. Aber jetzt mal, der Abend wurde lang. Und fünf Stunden am Stück ständig Sachen übersetzen. Also ich war auch wirklich am Anschlag. Aber es haben sich dann noch so viele Sachen daraus entwickelt. Ich will jetzt den Podcast nicht auf zwei Stunden länger quatschen. Aber irgendwann waren wir auf einer Polizeiwache, die kreisförmig ist. Also wie ein Ring. Warum, kann man nachlesen, ist architektonisch interessant. Und sitzen in so einem Raum. Da steht ein kleines Aquarium. Und da lehnt ein Bügelbrett an der Wand. Und da hängt ein ganz alter Stadtplan von Moskau. Und da wird nicht nur unser Protokoll getippt. Da sitzt jetzt auch noch so ein junger Student aus Ägypten, der irgendwie einige, also zig Kilometer weit weg von Moskau studiert, ein paar Tage in der Stadt war und sein Portemonnaie verloren oder geklaut hat. Der kommt jetzt nicht mehr zurück. Und die Polizisten sagen, wir sind auch nicht richtig, ob wir den verstehen. Können Sie den Fall auch mal gerade dolmetschen? Ja, und es waren einfach fünf Stunden von extrem eindringlicher Russland-Erfahrung mit unterm Strich nicht besonders schnellen, aber freundlichen Polizisten. Also wenn ihr mal nach Saransk wollt, ich habe jetzt sehr viele Tipps aus erster und zweiter Hand, was man da alles machen kann. Und irgendwann um kurz nach Mitternacht stehst du auf der Straße und denkst, haben wir das jetzt wirklich erlebt? Und der Knüller ist übrigens, was in dem Blogpost nicht steht, weil es erst am nächsten Morgen passiert ist, es endet halt damit, dass hier mein Freund fuhr wieder in sein Hotel, sollte dann noch mal gucken, ob er den Pass da hat und dann anrufen hat er mich angerufen, nein, ich gehe jetzt ins Badpass, ist hier nirgends. Ich sollte dann einen der Polizisten anrufen, hab ich auch gemacht, ja, der ist gut angekommen, nein, er hat den Pass nicht. Und am nächsten Morgen habe ich eine SMS von besagtem Freund, der um 5.30 Uhr aufrecht in seinem Bett saß und sich erinnert hat, wo der scheiß Kass war, nämlich in der Hose, die er am Tag vorher anhatte, weil er ihn nämlich in die Hosentasche gesenkt hat und nicht etwa wie er dachte, in seine Rucksacktasche. Das heißt, nach allem, was wir in dieser Nacht erlebt haben auf der Polizeiwache, sind wir am nächsten Tag dann natürlich wieder zur Polizei, weil man ja diese Anzeigerückabwickeln muss, denn sonst ist der ja ein Fall und muss als nächstes bei der Botschaft melden und so. So, damit habe ich jetzt also diese Woche sechs, sieben Stunden meines Lebens mit Moskauer Polizisten und Polizistinnen verbracht und es war lange nicht so gruselig, wie man das sonst so sich vorstellt und vor allen Dingen habe ich noch mal gemerkt, was es für einen Unterschied macht, ob du hier lebst oder ob du von außen reinkommst, weil als wir uns hinterher unterhalten haben, hat er halt immer gesagt, dass sich das für ihn an vielen Stellen sehr bedrohlich angefühlt hat, diese Situation, zum Beispiel am Anfang in der Metro, die Metropolizei, winziger Raum, Gittertür und plötzlich bist du der, der kein Russisch kann und vier reden auf dich ein, die haben alle Uniformen an und für mich hat sich das keine Sekunde bedrohlich angefühlt, weil man aber eben dann hier auch so wissen hat irgendwann, dass zum Beispiel die Tatsache, dass diese Menschen, denen du dazu tun hast, Und wenn du das zu tun hast, die ja nun Beamte sind, nicht lächeln oder kaum, dass die eigentlich fast immer ernst gucken. Dass das einfach hier so ist und dass das jetzt noch nicht heißt, hör mal, Junge, jetzt hier, ernste Sache, sondern es ist einfach, das ist das Neutrale. Ich hab gestern mit einer Freundin darüber geredet und wir haben es jetzt Resting Russian Face genannt. Oder Resting Bitch Face. Ich weiß nie, wie rum. Aber dass halt der neutrale Gesichtsausdruck für jemanden, der nicht weiß, wie hier ein neutraler Gesichtsausdruck ist, ernst, bedrohlich abweisend werden kann. Da gab es eine ganz super Geschichte auch von Steve Rosenberg von der BBC, kann man bei Twitter finden. Der war bei so einem Lächeltraining für, ich glaube, Eisenbahnmitarbeiter hier in Russland.
Ach, Wahnsinn. Ach, Mensch, Katrin, ich könnte mit dir so lange sprechen. Und das Lustige ist, wie wenig wir eigentlich über Fußball reden. Ich finde das aber überhaupt nicht schlimm. Für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die es interessiert, bei Russland ist die entscheidende Frage, ob sie in einem offensiven 3-5-2 spielen. Das hat Shachezov eigentlich so ein bisschen bevorzugt, ging aber nicht immer gut. Und Saudi-Arabien wird so spielen wie immer 4-2-3-1. Und wahrscheinlich wird es aber auch nicht das hochklassigste Spiel werden. Also ich habe noch nicht getippt in allen Tippspielen, in denen ich so mit drin bin, aber ich glaube, ich gehe auf 0-0.
Ich schließe mich deiner Expertise zum Spielaufbau natürlich total an, muss aber kurz noch zu Protokoll geben übrigens, dass ich neuerdings Kolumbien unterstütze und möchte, dass Kolumbien Weltmeister wird, weil nämlich ein Freund hier in Moskau jedes Mal zu WM so eine Lotterie organisiert. Jeder zahlt 100 Rubel in den Topf, bekommt dann ein Team zugelost und wenn dein Team Weltmeister wird, bekommst du den Topf. Also go Kolumbien, yeah yeah.
Sehr gut. Ja Kolumbien, das wäre zumindest eine sehr, sehr schöne Geschichte und Außenseiterchancen kann man denen schon zurechnen. Kolumbien hat eine geile Truppe überhaupt, es gibt ganz, ganz tolle Mannschaften und bevor wir jetzt enden, kann ich nur loswerden, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer auch, liebe Katrin, genießt diese Gruppenphase. Die Gruppenphase ist immer die schönste Zeit einer WM, denn es kann noch nichts passieren. Das größte, was passiert ist, dass man ein bisschen schadenfreudig sein kann oder Schadenfreude erlebt, weil die eigene Mannschaft stolpert. In der Regel scheiden aber die Mannschaften, für die man hier im europäischen Raum dann die Daumen drückt, sehr, sehr selten aus in der Gruppenphase und man hat noch dieses sichere Netz, dass es meistens noch ein Spiel gibt und noch ein Spiel und nur Fußball, den ganzen Tag nur Fußball. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, weil ich ganz viele Spiele davon nachts sehen werde, um sie nachzugucken. Aber trotzdem, den ganzen Tag nur Fußball. Genieß die nächsten zwei Wochen, danach fängt die K.o.-Runde an. Dann wird alles ein bisschen verkrampfter, verbissener.
Andererseits ist da dann auch mal ein spielfreier Tag zwischen. Das ist auch mal ganz gut, wenn man in der Phase vom Turnier ist. Dann kannst du mal deinen Schlaf nachholen.
Ja gut, ich mache ja trotzdem dann Sendungen und die spielfreien Tage sind für mich wahrscheinlich die Möglichkeit, dann auch mal die Journalistinnen und Journalisten anzurufen für den Kurzpass, die in Vatutinki sitzen bei der deutschen Nationalmannschaft, weil die haben halt eher dann mal Zeit.
Liebe Hörer, ihr habt das gehört. Wie der Max das sagt, ist das richtig. Vatutinki. Wir haben uns mit ein paar Leuten hier zusammengesetzt, die entweder in Russland leben oder es mal getan haben und haben uns so ein Russland-WM-Bericht-Erstattungstrinkspiel ausgedacht. Und immer wenn einer im Fernsehen oder im Radio Vatutinki sagt, müsst ihr einen trinken.
Vatutinki hört sich halt auch an wie bei Pippi Langstrumpf.
Takatuka, total.
Wahnsinn, ich werde mich sehr bemühen, es immer richtig auszusprechen. Katrin, ich danke dir ganz, ganz herzlich. Ich bin mir sicher, wir hören uns wann auch immer auch noch während der WM, nach der WM. Das kriegen wir auf jeden Fall hin. Ich wünsche dir eine wunderbare Zeit und vielen, vielen Dank für deine großartige Berichterstattung, die du vor der WM gemacht hast. Hier im Rasenfunk aber auch bei dir auf karscheib.de und auf ntv.
Ja, danke, dass ich so oft mit dir Podcasts machen durfte. Das hat total Spaß gemacht. Man ist da ja in guten Händen, dann kann man auch freier erzählen.
Ach schön, das freut mich. Dann wünsche ich uns allen... Go Kolumbien, ein schönes Turnier uns allen. Ja, macht's gut, ciao!